first night in LA Mickey D's let's do it
doing the right thing is always the
right thing right Nina yeah let's go
you're capable you could do more
[Music]
okay
it is day four of our West Coast
adventure this is a day I say good bye
Vanina No goodbye Rena first step got to
clean up our Airbnb I always try to make
sure the Airbnb that we stay in is
cleaner than when we found it it's the
Boy Scout rule but also these
entrepreneurs you know so many times you
hear Airbnb nightmares and people who
trashed your place and I want to do the
opposite I want I want the I want the
entrepreneur owner to come back home and
see just how amazingly beautiful it is I
want to be the best case where people
usually have nightmares I want to be the
holy cow this one guy did everything
make the beds
watch him a spotless the kitchen was
spotless that's always my goal so clean
up the rest of the condo and then head
up to the airport Mina's going to
Toronto and I'm going to it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter whose name it
is doesn't matter who gets the credit
doing the right thing is always the
right thing ready now yeah then we're
gonna take him to the airport she's
gonna go to Toronto and I'm coming to
see you guys and
[Music]
so Nina today this morning said aren't
you grateful that you have dry socks
again mmm yesterday was raining like
crazy in Vancouver and these shoes are
amazing to travel with but they're super
lightweight just piece of cloth
basically on top and I was walking
around and cold
wet socks cold feet cold wet socks for
hours four hours it's raining again
there and she's like I don't know how
you deal with it and when I'm faced with
that kind of adversity I tricked myself
this week really enjoy it this is no
option because I'm not gonna go barefoot
I don't have any other shoes I'm not
gonna buy another pair of shoes on the
mountain I have no option so when I'm
when I'm in a negative situation I have
no option then I tricked myself to say
this is awesome and I'm capable of more
and that this is my chance to grow and
show myself what I'm made of every time
every time I'm faced with an obstacle
and I and there's no way out in the
immediate future
then I tricked myself to say this is the
best and I use it as a way to build my
self-esteem that I am capable of more
that I am capable of more Nina bring
their wet feet Nina doesn't care Nina
doesn't care about the life lesson Nina
just wants to get to the airport okay
Nina you've heard she's heard it enough
for me but believe nations here let's go
I can't get an extra-large one sugar two
milk please thank you
[Music]
like the Vancouver stopover get a new
flight but LA let's go
[Music]
that's a nice-looking shirt cuz you're
wearing it
wow I'm gonna miss this one for the next
few days so
Nina's heading back to Toronto because
she's got she's got to go to work and
she's got to look after the dogs and I'm
going to LA because I've been invited to
speak at vid summit its Derral Eve's
event for YouTube is my third youtube
event of the year I think after this I'm
done for YouTube events for the year
[Music]
it's almost time to say bye to Nina
we're gonna miss you Nina we're gonna
miss you Nina
five days we'll see you soon bye Nina
we're gonna miss you bye Nina bye Nina
[Music]
that's rough saying goodbye to Hayden
yesterday and Nina today and I know it's
not goodbye to see you later
but it hurts still hurts I'm gonna get
on my plane in 20 minutes
and then bury myself in the work be
productive finish my to 54 confidence
book that'll make me feel good
[Music]
maybe tell a pretty decent flight now
time to hop my goober head to the hotel
[Music]
five four three all checked in let's go
find that room all right look at that
got our beds at the bathroom
got a coffee machine got me what up hey
we got a view of a roof and many roofs
this is one long table set up
I like it you guys know my usual setup
I'm not officially traveling until we
get some CNN happening anybody see it
Oh 21 21 yeah okay I'm going to have a
shower go get some food
probably just some work and then call it
in early so that I can wake up early and
hit la renta some local lobby here we
got nickname and what's going on is
going to you who's doing the 20 24 hour
live stream happy right now but they're
just hijacked he's - hijack rails last
yeah we got we got we got roberto blake
somewhere how do we there he is doing a
speech we're gonna go head out to dinner
bunch of YouTube creators
[Music]
okay those guys were taking a little too
long they're waiting on somebody and
giant groups is not usually my thing
anyway so I'm gonna just find something
quick because I am starving and then
head back talk to Nina do some work I
might just get something me McDonald's
is yelling close to here so much is
government god man I haven't had
McDonald's you know
so first night in LA Matisse let's do it
you know what I did promise myself I'd
be healthier and look what I found along
the way
subway healthy dinner options let's stay
healthy Evan
let's stay healthy let's get some subway
tonight feel good make yourself proud
I read somewhere that the the turkey sub
was the best one for you if you're going
meat so turkey sub with loads of veggies
pickles olives tomatoes spinach bunch of
other stuff so healthy milk combo no
cookie no chips no coke
just nutrition nutrition so that I can
stay healthy and keep making great
videos for you guys but in all
seriousness staying healthy while I'm
traveling is one of the hardest things
for me it's easy to let myself off the
hook you're not at home you don't have
all the things around you the usual
foods the healthy snacks at a lot of
these places it's all chips and cookies
and processed and packaged and it's hard
to stay healthy so it's awesome that
there is a subway next to me pretty
close walking distance and you make
these choices one one choice at a time
right one choice at a time I chose today
instead of going out with the group and
having Korean barbeque wherever they're
going to eat healthy
one choice at a time
it's never too late you know I didn't
eat the best today on the airplane and
the food that they gave me no real
option I had to eat because I was
getting a headache but now I have a
choice I have a choice you always have a
choice
you always has a choice to do the right
thing to do that extra step to make that
extra call put in that workout when you
don't feel like it you know there's
always distractions and things around
you to steer you off course and so this
is going to be a good test because when
you're in when I'm in my environment I'm
good like 95% of the time I'm really on
my schedule but when I'm away
I usually don't check anything and just
go all out and usually gain like 10
pounds so this is gonna be my challenge
and I'm pumped for it bring it on they
won by myself in LA healthy sub was
doing right into the main Derral Eve's
he's doing his he's he's finding his
uber but he's doing a 24 hour five-day
long livestream
it's breaking the game that's why
breaking the game expect nothing less
from Derral Eve's 10 o'clock ended up
hanging out with YouTube Birds a lot of
new fresh startups and you know me I
can't help it I can't help but I can't
help it I need to see people grow people
telling themselves stories and excuses
why they're not more successful and it
just I can't let it stand I can't let it
stand
nope nope that's not the reason why nope
nope that's not the reason why no that's
not it either
nope nope it's you let's go you're
capable and you could do more you have
the ability so therefore you have the
responsibility and everybody's getting
tired it's like you just get more energy
as the night goes on like yep yep I want
to scare and you
have to grow you guys have to learn from
this you guys have to make your channels
better what are we here for why are we
spending time away from our families why
are we spending money being here why why
why why you got to grow from this it's
not just some hangout social club that
we're part of you got to grow from this
and so that's what I do
yes what I do guys anyway it's ten
o'clock I got a I got a what time it's
like 1:00 a.m. for me I got a I gotta
sleep I didn't get any work done today
so I got a I got a film videos tomorrow
and then I'm doing my Meetup oh media
meetup with my fans at noon gotta film
videos and then I don't know what else
I'll take you guys on a journey we'll
see what happens if you want to see the
end of my Vancouver trip going up to
some crazy mountains and walking on the
edge of life and death almost it's
pretty scary though check that video
next to me I think you'll enjoy continue
to believe guys and I'll see you soon